♪
>> Greg: THE TRUMP
RE-ELECTION CAMPAIGN KICKS
OFF TONIGHT IN ORLANDO.
THAT'S IN FLORIDA.
>> Dana: THANK YOU.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT TO
EXPECT
♪ AND I GLADLY STAND UP NEXT
TO YOU.
>> I THOUGHT THAT WAS THE
SUN IN MY EYES.
IT'S THESE STUPID LIGHTS.
WHAT ARE THEY DOING?
THAT RUNWAY IS LIKE AN ICE
SKATING RINK.
[LAUGHTER]
AND THE FIRST STEP I SAID,
YOU KNOW, THIS SUCKER IS
SLIPPERY.
>> THIS IS THE WORST DAMN
STAGE I HAVE EVER SEEN.
>> COW CASS -- I LIKE I 10
MUCH BETTER.
DO YOU MIND?
>> LAST NIGHT I WATCHED
ALFRED E. NEWMAN.
>> BETO.
BETO IS FALLING FAST.
WHAT THE HELL HAPPENED?
I WAS MADE FOR THIS.
HE WAS MADE FOR IT.
HE WAS MADE TO FALL LIKE A
ROCK.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE HELL
HAPPENED TO BIDEN.
BERNIE, YOU KNOW BERNIE IS
CRAZY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: COMPARE ALL OF THAT
TO THIS.
>> MY NAME IS JOE BIDEN, I'M
RUNNING FOR IN THIS CASE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT IN THE
UNITED STATES.
LOOK ME OVER.
IF YOU LIKE WHAT YOU SEE
VOTE FOR ME IF NOT THE OTHER
PERSON.
>> I'M ENJOYING THIS PROCESS
OF RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
>> I WILL ALWAYS BE REAL
WITH YOU.
I WILL BE BOLD WITHOUT THE
BOLD.
>> Greg: YIKES.
IT'S A ROLLER COASTER VS.
THE LITTLE PONY CAROUSEL.
SANTA ELVES VS. THE BIG
ORANGE RHINO.
IT'S A FACT A TRUMP RALLY IS
REALLY FUN UNLIKE INFO
COMMERCIALS THAT INDUCE
VOMITING.
POWERS OF PERSUASION,
PRO-WRESTLING REALITY TV AND
CELEBRATE WROTE INTO ONE
FIREBALL.
HISTORICAL OR AND HYSTERICAL
FIRST.
TOO EARLY.
WHO CAN MATCH TRUMP FOR
THRILLS.
MEETING WITH DONALD WITH THE
DULL.
HERE IS WHAT TO CONSIDER
WHEN WATCHING TONIGHT'S
RALLY.
WHEN
WOEN
WOULD ANY OF THE ENERGY OR
HUMOR MAKE ANY SENSE IF
AMERICA WASN'T DOING GREAT?
WOULD ANY OF TRUMP'S WORDS
FEEL BIZARRELY OFF IF WE
WERE IN DEEP TROUBLE?
OF COURSE.
BUT THEY WON'T BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT.
IF THERE WERE BIG WARS,
UNEMPLOYMENT, HIGH CRIME, A
DEAD ECONOMY, THERE WOULD BE
NO PLACE FOR THIS AT ALL.
SURE, IF YOU ARE OBSESSIVELY
FURIOUS AT TRUMP WORST THE
TIMES.
MEASURE PERFORMANCE
PRACTICAL EVIDENCE AND NOT
HIS TWEETS OR BEHAVIOR IT
MIGHT BE THE BEST.
THE RALLY WILL BE FUN AND
LOUD AND UNPREDICTABLE
BECAUSE THE MITIGATION OF
OTHER BIGGER PROBLEMS MAKE
IT SO.
IN FACT, ALL THE STUFF FROM
IMPEACHMENT BLATHER TO MEDIA
MELTDOWNS ARE PRODUCTS OF AN
AGE WHEN BIG PROBLEMS ARE
BEING TACKLED IN NEW WAYS.
OF COURSE, MILLIONS WILL
LOVE THE RALLY.
MILLIONS WILL HATE IT.
AND MILLIONS WON'T CARE.
BUT THEIR ABILITY TO HAPPILY
DECIDE IS BROUGHT TO YOU BY
ONE STURDY FACT.
AMERICA IS BETTER OFF NOW
THAN IT'S BEEN IN YEARS.
ALL RIGHT.
SO, JUAN, MAYBE I POSE THIS
QUESTION TO YOU ENERGY ISN'T
WHAT AMERICA WANTS AFTER
FOUR YEARS.
MAYBE THEY WANT A COMFY
SWEATER.
MAYBE THE DEMOCRATS ARE
RIGHT TO COME AT THIS AND
MAYBE A MORE MUTED WAY.
>> Juan: I THINK THAT'S
RIGHT.
THIS IS A REFERENDUM ON
DONALD TRUMP.
DONALD TRUMP LOSES.
BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK AT THE
POLLS, HE IS UNDER WATER.
IS HE STRONGLY UNDER WATER.
SO HE HAS GOT -- DEMOCRATS
HAVE TO SAY HERE IS SOMEONE
WHO IS STABLE, SOMEONE WHO
IS RATIONAL, WHO DOESN'T
TWEET OFF CRAZY STUFF.
SOMEONE THAT YOU CAN TRUST
IN CRITICAL MOMENTS.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHY JOE
BIDEN RIGHT NOW HAS THE LEAD
AND I THINK LAST NIGHT I
READ HE SAID HE HAD
20 MILLION BUCKS IN THE
BANK.
HE IS REALLY RAISED MORE
MONEY THAN ANY OTHER
DEMOCRAT.
SO THOSE ARE ALL THE
REASONS.
I THINK THE ONLY STRATEGY
LEFT FOR TRUMP AND I THINK
WE WILL SEE IT TONIGHT AT
THE RALLY, GREG, IS FOR HIM
TO ATTACK AND SMEAR HIS
OPPONENT.
SO HE WILL TALK ABOUT THE
SOCIALIST.
HE IS GOING TO TALK ABOUT
NASTY WOMEN.
TIRED, SLEEPY JOE.
THAT'S WHAT HE HAS TO DO.
BECAUSE IF IT'S JUST ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP, HE LOSES.
SO HE HAS GOT TO, YOU KNOW,
NASTY UP HIS OPPONENT TO THE
POINT WHERE PEOPLE WOULD
SAY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
I WILL GO WITH TRUMP.
BY THE WAY, IN RESPONSE TO
YOUR THINGS, YOU ALWAYS SAY
THINGS ARE SO GREAT.
IF THINGS ARE SO GREAT,
GREG, WHY DID DEMOCRATS
CAPTURE 40 SEATS IN THE
MIDTERMS?
WHY ARE WE SENDING TROOPS TO
THE MIDDLE EAST?
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT IT'S
FARMERS ARE COMPLAINING
ABOUT THE LACK OF A TRADE
DEAL AND THE TARIFFS ARE
DRIVING UP PRICES AT WALMART
AND COSTCO?
THERE IS A REASON PEOPLE ARE
SAYING THIS GUY IS NOT A
GOOD PRESIDENT.
>> Greg: WHEN YOU COMPARE IT
TO THE OVERALL WORLD VIEW,
JESSE, LOW UNEMPLOYMENT,
BOOMING ECONOMY, A SHRINKING
MILITARY FOOTPRINT WHILE
HAVING A HUGE MILITARY, HE
DOESN'T NECESSARILY HAVE TO
INSULT ANYBODY.
CAN HE JUST GO BY HIS
RECORD.
>> Jesse: I CAN'T BELIEVE A
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO ATTACK
HIS POLITICAL OPPONENT,
JUAN.
HOW DARE THEM?
THAT'S NEVER HAPPENED
BEFORE.
>> Juan: NEVER HEARD OF IT.
JET
>>T
>> Jesse: I CAN'T BELIEVE A
REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT MIGHT
LOSE SEATS IN A MIDTERM.
THAT'S NEVER HAPPENED
BEFORE.
DIDN'T I SHOW YOU YESTERDAY
EVERY SINGLE PERSON THAT WON
THE PRESIDENCY SINCE 1984
HAD BEEN DOWN IN THE POLLS
IN JUNE AND THEY CAME BACK
AND WON?
>> Juan: THEY DIDN'T FIRE
THEIR POLSTER?
>> Greg: FOR LEAKING.
>> Jesse: YOU KEEP ON
DISRESPECTING THE AUDIENCE.
OF THE POLLS RIGHT NOW MEAN
NOTHING.
THE POLLS SAID HILLARY WAS
GOING TO BEAT TRUMP.
GOING TO BEAT TRUMP IN
FLORIDA ANSWERED WON BY
100,000 VOTES IN FLORIDA
AFTER BEING OUTSPENT 53 TO 1
DOWN THE STRETCH.
HE HAS, IN FLORIDA, TWO
REPUBLICAN SENATORS.
HE HAS GOT A REPUBLICAN
GOVERNOR.
AND THE QUINNIPIAC POLL
ACTUALLY SAID BOTH OF THOSE
GUYS DESANTIS AND SCOTT WERE
GOING TO LOSE BY SEVEN IN
THE MIDTERMS AND THEY WON.
SO THE FACT THAT NOW POLLS
SHOW FROM QUINNIPIAC BIDEN
BEATING TRUMP BY 7, IN
FLORIDA, DOESN'T REALLY MEAN
MUCH RIGHT NOW.
THE MEDIA KNOWS THERE IS NO
ONE THAT CAN COMPETE AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP AT THESE
RALLIES.
THEE SEE LINES.
THEY SEE PEOPLE IN TENTS
CAMPS OUT.
THEY SEE THE RAUCOUS
CONNECTION HE MAKES.
AND THE CROWD GOES WILD.
THEY WILL DO ANYTHING THEY
CAN TO DENIGRATE HIM.
BECAUSE THEY KNOW A DEMOCRAT
CAN'T PULL IT OFF.
THEY GOAL AFTER HIS
SUPPORTERS.
YOU WILL SEE REPORTERS ON
THE GROUND.
THEY WON'T INTERVIEW
HISPANIC OR BLACK TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
>> THEY WILL LOOK WITH THE
CRAZIEST PEOPLE WITH THE
MOST RADICAL SIGNS AND
ACTUALLY DEBATE.
THEY THE MORE THEY ATTACK
THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
SUPPORTERS, THE STRONGER
THAT CONNECTION GETS.
>> Greg: DANA, THE ONLY WAY
DEMS CAN GET PEOPLE SHOWING
UP IN TENTS IS BY MAKING
THEM HOMELESS.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.
NO, WHAT DO YOU EXPECT
TONIGHT OUT OF TRUMP?
I KNOW WHAT YOU ARE GOING TO
SAY, BUT I WANT YOU TO SAY
IT.
>> Dana: NO, PLEASE, WHY
DON'T YOU SPEAK FOR ME?
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK HE
SHOULD RAMBLE.
>> Dana: I WASN'T GOING TO
SAY THAT BUT I AGREE.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
>> Dana: NO, ACTUALLY PEOPLE
LOVE THE RAMBLING.
LAW TALKING ABOUT?
>> Greg: GOING LONG.
I DON'T THINK SO HE SHOULD
GO LONG.
>> Dana: I WILL LET YOU GIVE
HIM THAT ADVICE.
YOU JUST SHOWED THAT MONTAGE
WHICH IS HILARIOUS BECAUSE
HE WAS RAMBLING ABOUT THINGS
THAT ARE NOT IN THE SCRIPT
WHEN IS HE TALKING ABOUT THE
LIGHTS AND THE FLOOR AND
EVERYTHING.
I THINK THIS:  YOU CAN'T
CAPTURE LIGHTNING IN A
BOTTLE TWICE.
AND IF I WERE THEM, I WOULD
DOWN PLAY ALL COMPARISONS TO
2015.
NOW HE HAS A RECORD TO
DEFEND AND AS YOU SAY, YOU
KNOW, THE RECORD IS ALL OF
THESE AMAZING GREAT THINGS.
HE CAN TALK ABOUT THOSE
THINGS.
BEFORE HE WAS THE INSURGENT.
HE WAS THE I'M GOING TO COME
IN THERE AND SHAKE THINGS UP
AND I'M GOING TO BE THE
OUTSIDER AND HE HAS DONE ALL
OF THOSE THINGS.
BUT NOW HE ALSO IS AN
INCUMBENTS.
AND INCUMBENCY GIVES YOU SO
MANY TOOLS TO USE.
IT IS SO HARD TO BEAT AN
INCUMBENT PRESIDENT.
VERY, I HAVE
VERY VI HAVE
VERY VERHAVE
VERY VERYAVE
VERY VERY DE
VERY VERY DIFFICULT.
ONLY HAPPENED TWICE SINCE
WORLD WAR II.
THE POLLING RIGHT NOW
DOESN'T MATTER.
IT MATTERS FOR BIDEN TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO RAISE
MORE MONEY.
FOR THE POLLS THAT DOESN'T
REALLY MATTER.
YOU WILL SEE A LOT MORE
AFTER THE DEBATES.
I WOULD SAY HIS BIGGEST
STRENGTH RIGHT NOW THE WAR
CHEST IS HUGE.
GOT ALL OF THIS MONEY.
DIDN'T HAVE IT THE FIRST
TIME THE RNC FIRMLY BEHIND
HIM FROM THE JUMP A HUGE
AMOUNT OF ORGANIZATION.
ALL THESE GET-OUT THE-THE
VOTE PIECES NUMBERS THEY CAN
TALK TO.
PEOPLE GETTING THEIR CELL
PHONES WITH THEIR PICTURES
ON IT AND SEND IT TO THEIR
FRIENDS.
ALL OF THAT STUFF THEY
DIDN'T HAVE A WAY TO CAPTURE
IT BEFORE AND THEY DO NOW.
THAT SAID, IT'S STILL GOING
TO BE A BIG RACE.
THERE IS ALL OF THESE STATES
THAT THEY WILL HAVE TO PAY A
LOT OF ATTENTION TO.
>> Greg: EMILY, BRING US
HOME WITH THE MOST
THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS ON THIS
NETWORK TODAY.
>> Emily: GLAD TO.
WHAT IS SO TELLING AND ALSO
SHOULD BE SO ENCOURAGING TO
THE TRUMP TEAM RIGHT NOW IS,
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE WERE
WAITING IN LIBRARY FOR 40
HOURS TODAY.
AND THE CLOSEST WE HAVE EVER
SEEN TO SOMETHING LIKE THAT
WAS THE OBAMA NOMINATION IN
2008, RIGHT, AT THE DENVER
BRONCO'S STADIUM.
OBVIOUSLY THAT WAS MEDIA
REPORTED 75,000.
AMWAY ONLY HOLDS 20,000.
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A VERY
DIFFERENT EVENT.
THE POINT TO NOTE IS THAT
OBAMA FAILED TO GENERATE
THAT KIND OF ENTHUSIASM IN
2012 THE NEXT TIME AROUND.
AND HERE WE HAVE THE
INCUMBENT WITH PEOPLE
STANDING IN LINE FOR 40
HOURS FOR THIS ANNOUNCEMENT.
>> Dana: YEAH, TRUE.
>> Greg: THAT WAS GOOD.
>> Dana: S THAT WATT BEST
ANALYSIS ALL DAY.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
ORLANDO SENTINEL ALREADY
AHEAD OF THE RALLY ISSUED A
NON-ENDORSEMENT WITHOUT
KNOWING THE OTHER CANDIDATE.
ISN'T THAT KIND OF GARBAGE
ON THE PART OF THE PAPER?
>> Jesse: DOESN'T THAT TELL
YOU SOMETHING ABOUT TRUMP?
>> Greg: THAT'S AN EMOTIONAL
RESPONSE OF A PAPER.
THAT'S WHY NOBODY LIKES
THESE PAPERS IS THAT THAT IS
SO -- IT'S SUCH A DELUSIONAL
LIKE WE DON'T LIKE HIM.
WE DON'T CARE WHO IS RUNNING
AGAINST HIM.
THAT'S THE PAPER.
>> Juan: IF THEY SAY I
THOUGHTFUL PEOPLE THIS SAID
TOLER BY -- THIS IS UNSIGNED
HE HAD 20R8 BY THE WHOLE
NEWSPAPER.
>> Greg: AWNCH BEFORE
BABIES.
>> Juan: THEY ARE SAYING THE
STATE OF THE COUNTRY.